well
here we are again
eight years later
i'm trevor hasty
and this is
my friend uh
rob
rob
tip charani
thank you my old buddy trevor
may i say you haven't changed one bit
you look great oh thank you rob
well we're here filming the second
edition of our mooc lectures on our
course
intraduction
to statistical
learning cisco learning
you can take your costume off now
it's all from oh okay sorry
so
welcome to the second edition of our
lectures on statistical learning uh we
have some new lectures to accompany the
new edition of our book
and the new lectures will be on deep
learning
survival analysis and multiple testing
as long as a few other topics in
addition you'll you'll notice if you
look in the book which is also freely
available on our websites and on the
bookway
website you'll notice there's a few
little
extra pieces in various chapters so
in chapter four we have a new section on
generalized linear models
in in the unsupervised learning chapter
we have a section on matrix completion
and uh
there's one more
bart in the tree the tree uh chapter um
bayesian additive regression models bart
the rest of the course is the same as
before so we haven't reformed those
lectures the material is the same
and of course there's there's labs for
the new material as well so we hope you
enjoy it in addition
um if in the in the in the first edition
of the course we had interviews with
some famous uh people in our field well
we have more of those
right we've added uh with interview with
david cox on survival analysis
jeff hinton
on deep learning and joaf benjamini for
multiple testing and false discovery
rates so we hope you enjoy the second
edition of the course